la chimie en agriculture représentent
des contraintes agronomique économique
et sur la santé
lui c'est paul françois le premier
agriculteur français à avoir attaqué
monsanto en justice c'était en 2007
le céréalier accuse la multinationale de
l'avoir intoxiqué via son herbicide le
lasso des produits phytosanitaires
dangereux pour la santé
dès les années 70 certains agriculteurs
en était conscient comment êtes vous
venu à bannir les éléments chimiques
dans votre culture
c'est venu parce que j'ai manqué de
m'empoisonner avec les traitements la
suite de traitement assez répété j'ai
craché le sang pendant plusieurs jours
et c'est ce qui m'a décidé à arrêter
totalement parce que non seulement je
m'en prenais mais je me suis aperçu que
j'emploie zone et les autres aussi
à cette époque les agriculteurs
utilisent le pesticide ddt reconnus
dangereux et cancérogène
il est interdit de vente en 1972 est
toujours dans les années 70 les
chercheurs de l'inra l'ours des études
afin de connaître exactement les impacts
de ces produits sur le producteur dans
le champ mais aussi sur les
consommateurs de ces produits traités
chimiquement vous considérez vous que
c'est fondamental du point de vue de
l'utilisation des pesticides en
agriculture par exemple a bien sûr c'est
fondamental car il est impensable qu'on
puisse utiliser à notre époque un
produit dont on ignore manifestement les
effets à long terme la dangerosité pour
l'agriculteur est reconnue mais pas
assez prise en compte selon so
toxicologue en 1978 il milite pour un
équipement total de l'agriculteur afin
de se protéger
l'ouvrier sur le champ et plus jeunes
agriculteurs que montre fois il ne
regarde pas le soleil se levait la pluie
tombée il pulvérise des produits
toxiques donc c'est un ouvrier exposés
malgré ces alertes l'agriculture
française poursuit son industrialisation
à l'aide de ses produits phytosanitaires
seule condition pour avoir plus de
rendement selon sa défense
mais les agriculteurs intoxiqué passant
au bio dénoncé déjà un appauvrissement
de la terre pollution des sols est un
danger pour la santé cette interrogation
de ce journaliste en 1973 semble
terriblement actuel mais avant tout ne
pourrait-on pas savoir si les services
rendus par les pesticides l'emportent
toujours sur les inconvénients qu'ils
entraînent
[Musique]